it looks like Cheryl Burke is making her
way back into the ballroom
you're in for a freaking treat guys a
source tells ET that the 33 year old
dancer will return as a pro for season
25 of Dancing with the Stars
quote she's really excited to return to
her roots she doesn't want to let anyone
down so you can expect she will be
bringing her a-game every night Cheryl
left the show indefinitely after
competing with Ryan Lochte during season
23 to pursue other projects like dance
bombs and her North American love on the
floor tour which has been postponed
until 2018 ET was with Cheryl as she
prepped for the international leg of the
tour and she admitted she hadn't totally
closed the door on Dancing with the
Stars reducing yourself going back in
some capacity absolutely now that her
schedule has opened up returning to the
hit ABC show seems like a no-brainer our
source tells ET that a better paycheck
and job consistency played a role in her
decision to return the news comes
shortly after Good Morning America
announced the other pros that will be
competing this season including this
surprise
the celebrity competitors for the new
season will be revealed on September 6th
on GMA